imposible celebrar elecciones en libia
al menos hasta el 24 de enero fecha
propuesta por la comisión electoral esto
después de que el parlamento remitiese
un informe en el que cancelaba las
elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias previstas para el viernes
24 de diciembre la insuficiencia de
legislación electoral con respecto al
papel del poder judicial en apelaciones
y disputas electorales y el solapamiento
existente entre políticos y sentencias
llevó a la comisión a la incapacidad de
fijar el 24 de diciembre como fecha de
votación la cancelación se debe a
disputas entre el poder judicial y el
político especialmente en la designación
de candidatos
opciones como el hijo del exdictador
muamar gadafi el líder de las milicias
del este jalifa haftar y el primer
ministro interino adelaide baiba fueron
excluidos pero tras apelar fueron
restituidos por tribunales pese a sus
condenas esta tensión ha desembocado en
movilizaciones de grupos armados
dificultando la celebración de comicios
como explica la analista amanda kadlec
la potencial violencia el día de las
elecciones
acción de votantes son posibilidades
reales y mientras siga siendo así no
será posible llevar elecciones libres y
justas
las naciones unidas y la comunidad
internacional siguen insistiendo en la
celebración de comicios así habló el
embajador de eeuu en libia no es el
momento de acciones unilaterales o
despliegues armados los líderes libios
deben abordar urgentemente todos los
obstáculos para la celebración de
elecciones estas elecciones sean la
esperanza para poner fin a más de 10
años de caos tras la caída de gadafi en
2011 y después del alto el fuego
negociado por rusia y turquía en 2020
entre el gobierno reconocido por la onu
en trípoli y las fuerzas del mariscal
jalifa haftar basados en tobruk